eine überwachungskamera hielt den moment
des aufschlags fest bei dem absturz
eines passagierflugzeugs in der nähe der
russischen hauptstadt moskau sind nach
nun offiziellen angaben alle 71 menschen
an bord ums leben gekommen
die maschine sei am sonntag weniger als
zehn minuten nach dem start vom moskauer
flughafen domodedowo von den
radarschirmen verschwunden berichteten
die behörden
die trümmer liegen verstreut auf einer
länge von mindestens einen kilometer
angesichts dieses großen gebiets nutzen
die ermittler nun equipment wie drohnen
um einen überblick aus der luft zu
bekommen da guckt mit blick auf die
ursache des absturzes erklärten die
behörden man ermittle in verschiedene
richtungen unter den hypothesen seien
die wetterbedingungen der technische
zustand der maschine und menschliches
versagen die besatzung hatte keine
notrufe gesendet zur zeit des absturzes
herrschten moderatem minus temperaturen
und leichter schneefall
das flugzeug der saratov airlines war
nach ost im gebiet orenburg unterwegs
auch dort würden angehörige versorgt
erklärte der stellvertretende
gesundheitsminister russlands momentan
arbeiten lokale mediziner und
psychologen mit den angehörigen am
morgen soll dann auch eine
regierungsmaschine nach auffliegen und
medizinisches personal dorthin bringen
um die familien und verwandten seelisch
zu unterstützen
auch die identifikation der opfer wird
derzeit vorbereitet
die fluggesellschaft erklärte es habe
keine technischen probleme mit dem
flugzeug gegeben dass seit 2016 in ihrem
besitz sei maschine des typs antonov 148
wurde 2010 gebaut